اربعه زلازل كبيره ضربت تركيا خلال الايام
الماضيه وتناولنا تداعياتها الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه الليله نبحث في الاثار
الاقتصاديه التي سينتجها الزلزال عشرت
مليارات دولار رقم مبدئي لحجم الاضرار في
المباني كاقل تقدير وهو الرقم الاكثر
تفائلا على فكره اضافه لسنوات من العمل
المتواصل المتوقع قبل عوده الاوضاع الى ما
كانت عليه قبل الزلازل البنك الاوروبي
لاعاده الاعمار وتنميه قدر ان الاثار
الاقتصاديه للزلازل قد تتسبب في خساره تصل
الى واحد في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لتركيا صحيفه احوال تركيا تحدثت
الى خبراء اقتصاد ذكروا ان معدل النمو في
العام الجاري قد ينخفض الى 1% بعدما كانت
التحليلات تشير الى احتمال تسجيل نسبه نمو
تتراوح بين الثلاثه والثلاثه ونصف في
المئه ما يعني خساره تقترب من عشرين مليار
دولار
نمو التضخم ايضا في طريقه للارتفاع في
تركيا بعدما كانت نسبه التضخم الاخيره
المعلنه الشهر الماضي
58% نتذكر هنا ان نسبه التضخم تجاوزت
اواخر العام الماضي 80% مع سياسه الحكومه
لخفض اسعار الفائده كذلك يوجد اجماع في
التقديرات والتقييمات الاقتصاديه بان
تركيا ستواجه دون شك ازمه عمله جديده
بينما الليره شهدت سابقا هيارات متتاليه
كما نذكر بدءا من عام 2018 وفقدت قرابه
50% من قيمتها جانب اخر سلبي يتعلق بعجز
التجاره الخارجيه التركيه التي سجلت تركيا
عجزا قياسيا فيها بلغ 110 مليارات دولار
العام الماضي وتوقع بنك الاستثمار
الامريكي مورجان ستانلي ان تضيف زياده
الواردات في هذه الفتره عبئا اضافيا قدره
تسعه مليارات الى العجز
وسائل اعلام تركيا تداولت الاثر الاقتصادي
للزلزال الذي كانت ولايه قهرمان مرعش
مركزه الولايات المتحده
الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال الاول تسهم
بنحو 10% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
وتتركز في منطقه الكارثه انشطه الزراعه
وتربيه الحيوانات والانتاج الصناعي قهرمان
مرعشه التي كانت الاكثر تضررا تحقق منفرده
سته 36% من انتاج الغزل في تركيا بينما
ثلث الانتاج التركي من الحمضيات ياتي من
اضنه وفيها طاي نجد اكبر مصنع للحديد
والصلب بينما تبرز ولايات متضرره اخرى في
مجال السياحه وانتاج الحبوب والقطن وحتى
قبل الزلزال كانت تركيا تواجه معوقات في
الانتاج الزراعي في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه كالجفاف وتباطؤ الانتاج اضافه
لمشاكل تتعلق بالاعلاف اليوم ازاح الزلزال
الستاره عن وضع قاتم فمع المشاكل السابقه
ضرب الزلزال البنيه التحتيه الزراعيه
وتسبب في نفوق الالاف من رؤوس الماشيه
وبدايه حركه نزوح للمزارعين صحيفه احوال
التركيه نقلت عن خبير اقتصادي قوله ان ما
تحتاجه تركيا حاليا هو وضع استراتيجيه
انتاج متكامله لانعاش اقتصاديات المدن
المتضرره من الزلزال في الفتره المقبله في
محاوله للوصول الى وضع مقارب نسبيا لما
كان عليه الحال قبل الزلزال
[موسيقى]